for many of us there are the things we
do to make a living and the things we do
out of passion the real gift is when
those two become one this morning on a
special edition of the dish when that
happened for a former Texas truck driver
his success was baked in that is my red
velvet cake and it is the best red
velvet cake in the world the best mark
Lennon says because baking has long been
both his passion and pastime when did
you decide I can make this my full-time
it actually happened maybe a little more
than a year ago I was in the barber shop
getting my hair cut and my barber was
playing this piece by Steve Harvey when
the alarm clock goes off in the morning
and you ain't happy about it you ain't
doing what you want to do see you
fighting upstream you're going against
what God created you for and there was
something about that that just really
hit me because I'm a truck driver
you're a truck I'm a truck driver I was
like I'm certainly not that passionate
about driving this truck every day but I
am passionate about baking I decided to
give it a go how's that you know what
why not why not me let's give it a try
and brother banks was born tell me about
this name where'd it come from
um well the name came from well I'm a
brother that bakes so when you think
about it though I mean like some of the
best desserts in America come from black
people yeah but I don't know if black
men have that reputation well about to
change all of that
yeah each week linen bakes and ships
hundreds of jars packed with his
signature cakes his inspiration
delicious childhood memories growing up
my mom used to bake all the time she
would make all these wonderful desserts
for us and I was just sitting the
kitchen just study her and just see what
she was doing that was just sit and
observe and I picked up a few things
along the way and when she stopped
baking I decided to take over why did
you do this aside from this passion of
yours to bake was there something else
I've always felt like
God wanted something else for me I
wasn't sure what but I've tried
different businesses failed and I just
there was something else out there I
knew there was something else for me to
do
linen studied Fine Arts with dreams of
becoming a marketing director but when
his career in graphic design stalled he
pivoted to pay the bills so that's why I
decided to drive a truck and it's been
good it pays the bills but it's never
been the long-term goal for me instead
the goal is to build a legacy and
inspire his young sons as long as these
stereotypes I've been dealing with them
all of my life at 6'5 everybody assumed
I play basketball I'm honestly not that
good at basketball
and I want my kids to feel like they
have to conform to what society say they
should be I want them to go out and do
whatever they feel they're comfortable
doing or happy doing brother bakes
offers up brownies and half a dozen cake
varieties each with playful celebrity
names sakes we have choco con chocolate
cake oh yeah we also have the Jermaine
Dupri
it's a German chocolate cake we have the
banana Ross which is a banana pudding
cake we also have Mariah carrot which is
my carrot cake and we have ready Murphy
which is red velvet there we go
we whipped up the ready Murphy all right
so now we get to the point where we
build the jar smooth red velvet cake
layered with a cream cheese icing top it
off stick it in and you put more on it
business was booming
but then came coded 19 linens revenue
dwindled until next insurance featured
him in a campaign to boost small
businesses around the country I'm Marlon
next Insurance has hired me to do what I
do best let's build delicious desserts
and show them off in this commercial
started off I was getting maybe three or
four orders a week now we're at right
around 120 to a hundred and forty jars
which is equivalent of maybe 30 to 40
orders I've increased tenfold in half a
year in half a year what is the next
step the next step is continuing to grow
to the point where we're out of the
kitchen so you know that's when I'm
getting my commercial kitchen possibly a
retail space and by his side his kids
Israel and Zion and wife Quan yeah where
do you see this going I see him doing
this full-time to be honest with you I
see it becoming international big dreams
driven by a philosophy life is what you
make of it
my favorite part is business if I'm
being honest is the time I do get to
spend when the boys help me out it's
just a special moment that I can't
replace that with anything I want them
to see that there's no limits it's never
too late to change your mind or change
path just find something that you're
passionate about and go for it and Dana
and Jeff my god baby free yeah well
there's you know I'm wondering why Steve
Harvey doesn't have his own flavor I
mean he inspired this whole thing